hola buenas tardes bueno gracias sobre
todo al heroísmo de los pasajeros de ese
tren había 750 250 solamente en ese
carro donde estaba
alcázar y recordemos que cuando él sale
del baño de ese está lisa armado con un
fusil de asalto con 300 municiones con
un cuchillo y con una pistola en el
bolsillo dos pasajeros un francés y un
franco estadounidense lo detienen
intentan controlarlo de hecho uno de
ellos le quita el fusil pero al casa ni
sacó un arma que tiene el bolsillo lo
hiere gravemente y ahí es cuando llegan
los famosos estadounidenses esos tres
amigos de la infancia dos de ellos
militares que logran definitivamente
controlarlos pero en esa pelea alcanzan
y saca un cuchillo que tiene en el
bolsillo y viene y era uno de ellos
finalmente logran amarrarlo con las
corbatas de los pasajeros y uno de los
militares además ayudó a la persona que
había quedado gravemente herida hasta la
llegada de los servicios de urgencia
ellos los tres estadounidenses que
recibieron la legión de honor de parte
del presidente françois hollande y que
luego se convirtieron a la ciudadanía
francesa también que ya no son más
soldados que son prácticamente
personalidades
en eeuu ellos van a participar de este
juicio van a venir al final de esta
semana porque quieren ver dijeron los
ojos de la persona quienes ellos
lograron controlar ese terrible día de
agosto del año 2015
alan también debía participar clint
eastwood recordemos que él hizo una
película que fue protagonizada por los
mismos jóvenes pero no ha respondido a
la convocatoria